Welcome friends, whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home.
It's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Kurt Busch.
Now, Kurt is a certified internal family
systems practitioner,
trauma-informed coach, and co-founder of
Brimstone Coaching Group.
We're going to get back to that title here
in just a minute.
Please,
yes.
With a background spanning corporate
leadership,
pastoral ministry, and coaching,
helps leaders break free from self-doubt,
embrace authenticity, and lead with
confidence.
Kurt, welcome to Phoenix in Flame.
Hey, thanks. Glad to be here. Nice to
spend some time with you here,
Dana.
This is gonna be fun. Okay, now I have
more to say about you,
but first I can't let it go. Brimstone
Coaching Group,
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
mean, wow,
that's like, when you think of Brimstone,
you think of like the Hellfire and
Brimstone.
It's like, where did you come up with that
name?
Well, it's funny you say that Dana there
is about 50 % of the people
we talked to that have the same exact
reaction you had And you said you're
in Tennessee. I'm like, okay, this might
be a thing ~ So here's here's
the here's the reality ~ You know this
that butterflies are the only living
creature
that transforms that literally transforms
in their lifetime
~ The brimstone butterfly is a species of
butterfly and it is
the longest living species of butter.
It lives the longest
transformed life of all butterflies.
So we wanted to capture we believe
transformation is possible.
We wanted to capture that with some
butterfly imagery.
And you know, we are not marketing folks
maybe did
not think through the 50 % of the
population that hears brimstone
and think something a little more like,
~ yeah, hellfire, brimstone, pounding the
pulpit sort of thing.
But we are not pounding on any pulpits
now.
But you know, and I love that explanation.
When I think of Brimstone too,
in terms of a coaching group, I think that
being finally scared enough
of what's going on in your own life to do
something about it.
Hmm ~
Because
to be honest, we kind of know that we're
all walking around in varying levels
of pain.
Yeah.
And there's this, I'm sure you've heard of
it,
the pain threshold that...
Yeah.
And for those of you who are listening or
watching and you don't know what
the pain threshold is, it's like before
any of us are willing to do
the work of change, now listen closely,
the pain of staying the same has to become
worse than the pain of change.
Which means we don't want to change
because we don't like
it and sometimes we have to be finally
scared enough.
in enough fear of our own life that we're
finally willing to do the work of change.
So when I think of Brimstone Coaching
Group,
that's also what comes to my mind.
Yeah, that's interesting. Thanks for
saying it like that.
That's
a more gracious understanding than we get
sometimes.
So thanks. ~
All right, now I want to add a few other
things in here to help
my listeners and viewers understand a
little bit more about you and
so much fun stuff to talk about.
you said that you have overcome your own
struggles with imposter syndrome,
which we definitely are going to hover
over that for a moment,
that you're passionate about guiding
others through transformational growth
into
authentic leadership and you have your own
unique ERT approach.
which we can get to and that. So,
Kurt, let me pause and stop talking so
much and give you some space
to like where you can start wherever you
like.
If you want to start kind of where you
started from in childhood
or start current and work around.
I'm really interested in you as a person
and what brought you to this place
in life where you're doing all these
things.
I mean, why this? Why now?
Yeah, that's a great question,
Dana. I don't know. No, just kidding.
~ Yeah. News to me.
I love it! You got me!
~
Yeah. So I have a weird, unique
background.
Yeah. I mean, there's certainly some
childhood stuff.
mean, I am a coach. I'm not a clinical
therapist.
So I do know like my lane when I talk
about trauma,
mean, little t trauma. I've got some
little t trauma from my childhood where
there
was some really
~ deeply embarrassing or painful kind of
moments as a kid that,
that kind of shaped how I showed up as an
adult leader,
~ which I know we're speaking the same
language there.
Yeah. So, so my, my like leadership began
in,
in a manufacturing world where I was kind
of swimming in waters
I probably didn't belong in. ~ And like,
I mean that not in a self-deprecating way,
but ~ I, I, I was fortunate enough to have
some doors open up for me that were
really good at a really good time in my
life.
~ I was just a kid leading a team of
people in a manufacturing plant that
I didn't know what I was doing.
Right? Like I was I was doing the thing
that I hate.
I was kind of faking it until I make it.
I hate that now as a coach, but I didn't
know what I was doing.
I got to do some recruiting. I did labor
recruiting for the entire plant
for a season. And that was really great.
I love
I loved the place I worked. love the
people I work with.
And then I went to seminary as an adult,
which is really dumb. ~ No,
it's not dumb. was ~ just a huge life
change.
~ I went to seminary in my ~ 30s.
There's another story for another time.
I didn't have a bachelor's degree.
The seminary I went to had some processes
where they allowed students to come in,
non-traditional students to come in and
get their M.Div.
So I did that late in life and it was
really in that season of seminary that
I realized like, man, there is some
imposter stuff going on here.
I'd never written a master's level paper.
I'd never sat in rooms of people that I
consider to be,
you know, levels of, you know,
exponentially smarter than I am.
I don't know if that's true. I still don't
know how true that is,
but that was the feeling. ~ And that sort
of imposter syndrome that started there,
carried with me into my first local church
position.
That was a pretty challenging season to
just kind of uncover.
I had a good coach before I knew how to do
this work for myself and with others.
I had a really good coach that helped me
kind of navigate and uncover some things
that I didn't know were present.
~ Yeah, I mean, I think once that started
to get uncovered in me,
just sort of...
happy, it's kind of cascaded of like,
found this and then I found this and I
found this.
And again, had a good coach to work with
me through that in a kind
of gentle and invitational way.
you
Yes. So I was pastoring a church in 2020.
~ Long story real short. I don't know.
Do you remember 2020? Yeah.
~ yeah right, I think I do, yeah,
I think we remember that. Yeah,
There were a couple of things going on.
a couple things.
Yep. Yep. So I started, we launched a
campus of a church.
helped launch a campus on January 1st of
2020,
which is wild in and of itself and
difficult in and of itself.
But then in March to have a pandemic hit,
I had to shift into full like help my
leaders lead well mode.
I didn't know it, but I needed to coach my
volunteer leaders so that they could lead
well. And what I found in that is I loved
that work way more than
I loved organizational leadership.
I'm just...
If I'm honest, like I just don't like
organizational leadership.
don't, I don't get energy from sort of
being the organizational leader that casts
a vision and like, let's go in this
direction.
I, don't love that sort of leadership.
~ so then over the course of the next
couple of years after that,
transitioned my career into, know,
how do I do more of the work that I love
and gives me energy and sort
of transition away from the stuff that
drains me more.
Wow, and that's really powerful right
there.
And we can wrap back around to that about
being in a space in your life where you're
trying to diminish and turn away from the
things that just suck the energy
out of you so that you have energy left
for the things that you really love.
I feel that to my bones, okay?
I know exactly what that is like.
And if you don't pivot, then well...
I'm going to say something that sounds
kind of cheesy,
but if you don't pivot, you're going to
perish.
know, pivot or perish because that's what
that's going to happen.
Now, I wanted to take a moment and hover
over imposter syndrome.
That's what you mentioned. Even starting
as such a young,
you know, young man and you were in the
manufacturing industry
and leading other people older than you.
Imposter syndrome is strong and it's very
prevalent.
~ It just eats people alive in various
platforms and various arenas where they
feel
like, I can't do this.
Other people seem
Yeah.
to think I can, but I don't think I can do
this.
And so we had said earlier,
we mentioned the internal family systems,
which I love, use in my keynote,
my mental boardroom ~ aspect of that part
of us.
that's in there saying, you need to get
out of here.
You are not qualified. They're gonna find
you out and it's gonna be embarrassing.
Yeah. Yeah.
What was your, let's just hover over that
particular experience that
you had and what was that like for you so
we can really connect with
the people that are listening or watching
that they're like,
my gosh, that's, I'm feeling that right
now.
I'm experiencing that right now.
Yeah, yeah, you know, in the moment I
couldn't verb.
I just want to say in the moment I didn't
know any of this in the moment,
like as a young adult learning these new
roles,
I didn't know how to do. I thought this
was just normal.
Like I thought this is what it meant to
adult.
If I can use that as a verb, right?
I just thought this is just what everybody
this is the cost of leadership,
right? That I'm going to feel exhausted
that I'm going to walk into a room and
like
have to scan around to figure out who's
smarter than me,
or, you know, I'm going to have to like
fear every time my phone dings when I'm
off,
you know, one of those sorts of things.
I just thought that was normal.
~ I know now that it's, that it's not,
you know, like that happens in our own
experiences.
We just imagine everybody feels the same
way.
~
Mm-hmm.
But, but it really was that it was really
walking into a room,
fearing like, ~ is this the meeting?
Like, is this the one where my,
manager is like,
you're right. We made, we made a bad
choice.
You got to go. Right. ~ or, know,
what happens if I don't know how to answer
the question that I get
a phone call about, you know, like what,
what then, what's that going to mean for
me,
my family? I mean, it just builds and
builds and builds.
just, feels like a house of cards is what
it feels like in the moment.
Yes. That's a very good analogy.
just waiting for a strong wind.
Yeah. That's always stuck with me.
It feels like a house of cards waiting for
a strong wind.
And like, how do I, you you talk about
IFS,
like how, how does my firefighter and my
manager like just block the wind?
Like that's what it feels like.
that, that didn't like, again,
I didn't know this was abnormal in those
years.
It wasn't until seminary where like I'm,
submitting a master's level paper and I'm
hovering over submit on my computer
and I can't click submit. Right.
Like it's this fear of like, this is the
paper.
This is the one.
Yeah, it's just exhausting. It's just
exhausting.
my goodness, I can relate to this so much.
have shared with people on my journey on
doing,
because I'm a serial entrepreneur.
So I've had a
Yeah.
private practice for 18 years.
Absolutely adore it. Then the podcast and
now I'm in the speaking ~ arena
Mm.
and trying to build that and get my
message out to help ~ high performers
not get burned out and love it,
have a lot of passion for that.
But there's a lot of things like you
mentioned earlier that go along the way.
There's a lot of things, there's a lot of
things you have to learn and level
up and you get exposed to a lot of people.
And to be honest, there's times that I've
wanted and a few times I literally did,
crawl under my covers in a fetal position
and just pull the covers right
up to my chin. And I tucked them all
Yeah. Yeah.
around and I just feel like,
how long can I just stay here under my
Yeah.
covers? Because I think I, you know,
I don't know if I can...
I don't know if I can do this.
How long can the whole house of cards
waiting for that stiff wind?
It's a thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What helped you to manage that
and to pull through it? And before you
answer that,
because I want to just kind of float out,
it's one thing if...
if we're being beaten, if we're competing
and we're being beaten,
like imagine a team. It's one thing if the
other team is beating us,
right, because they're better.
That's one thing. It's another
Yeah. Yeah.
thing if we're beating ourself.
If
Yes.
we don't even need the other team to do it
because we're beating our own self,
right?
Yes.
So that's how I view imposter syndrome.
We're not waiting for the other team
because to be honest,
there are people out there that are
smarter than us,
better than us, more creative than us,
faster than us. That's true. That will
Yeah, yeah,
always be true.
And if they are, they are. And kudos
yeah, yeah.
and I wish the best for them. But it's one
thing to be beaten legitimately
by someone else or bettered by someone
else.
It's one thing when we beat ourself.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you're spot on.
mean, I often think about the inner critic
being so close in this conversation
to imposter syndrome. Like not everything
Mm-hmm.
the inner critic says is ~ to be set
aside.
Like sometimes the inner critic is helping
us,
right? Sometimes the feeling of like,
man, I might not exactly know what I'm
doing.
That can actually empower us, right?
Like there's not...
There's not a complete good or complete
bad in these conversations.
Sometimes the imposter syndrome is like
spurring us to get better,
right? There are things we can learn.
There are things we can improve on for
sure.
So I'm glad you said that. Here's what I
found in my own personal imposter
syndrome.
What I think we see in our clients too is
that it's not really about the skills.
It's not really about...
what I know or what I don't know,
it's about the fear that I think is gonna
happen if it's not true.
~ You know, like we talk a lot about
little T trauma.
I think that little T trauma comes back in
all those places that remind
us that this is a dangerous situation and
if I get found out something
bad is gonna happen, something dangerous
or uncomfortable is gonna happen.
So for me, I needed a good coach that
could help me ask the question,
what's true right now? Right, so ~ we...
Can I tell a quick story? Okay.
yeah, absolutely, I love stories.
Do tell.
So
when I started working for this,
for the last church I worked for,
it was a big church, two campuses,
lots of staff. we also,
like the main campus is in a town with a
small Christian college.
And it was not uncommon to sit around a
table with professors and
to talk about like, what are we gonna do
this week in terms of preaching
or the text or whatever. And I would find
myself in that room like scared.
talk, scared to share my opinion of what I
thought because there's like professors
across the table. So my imposter syndrome
was for me was saying,
you don't belong here. And if you talk,
they're going to think you're dumb,
right? Or they're going to not invite you
to this table.
And I so badly wanted to be at the table.
So, so I needed a good coach to ask me the
question of like,
is that true? Because so much of this
imposter syndrome lives in the dark.
So much of this lives
in the realm of being unsaid and unnamed.
So I needed a coach to ask me,
what would happen if you spoke up?
Or what would happen if you shared an
opinion once in the next meeting?
Not like full on like, you know,
both feet in, like, can you dip a toe in
and try and see what would happen?
You know, so I need the question of what's
true.
Like in this moment, I need to ask Kurt
the question.
What's true? Are they gonna withdraw from
me?
Are they gonna think I'm dumb?
Are they gonna make me leave the room or
never invite me back?
And sure, sometimes the answer might be
yes,
but often the answer is no. Often the
answer is definitely not.
That was probably something that was real
years ago for me,
not anymore.
That is a ~ wonderful story. I love that.
I mean, I think we all can relate to being
in scenarios very similar to that.
And what I heard you saying in that
description was you were essentially,
and your coach was helping you to
essentially vet the men in that room.
I assume they were men or were there women
in there too,
Men and women. Yeah, men and women,
okay, to
yeah.
vet the people in that room for safety
because we are,
We are supposed to do that. We have a
responsibility to ourselves
to vet our environment. Is this a safe
place to be authentic?
Are these individuals going to accept my
authenticity?
Are they going to respect? Are they going
to provide safe space for
me to be authentic? Or are they going to
be jackasses?
Which, ~
Yeah, yeah, good word.
I mean, that's...
We've been there, right? And we've been
around those
Yeah, yeah.
people and we can kind of tell how they're
speaking and how they're acting,
their body language, their tone of voice,
their facial expressions. We're thinking
this person has jackass written
all over them. So we absolutely have a
right to vet
Yeah.
people.
Yeah. Yeah. The vetting mixed with
courage.
I think those two combined, think for me,
it was like the winning combination.
~ You know, I do think there is a level of
courage that has
to be employed when I don't know how to
completely vet.
Like I knew these people had, you know,
other people could vouch. I know the
person running the meeting,
but at the end of the day, whenever humans
are present,
there's always a risk of danger,
right? So then, you know, we use the
language,
like, how do I take a half step outside of
my comfort zone?
Like, that's different all the time,
you know? And I get to decide what that
looks like.
But I wonder if that courage piece has to
go along with
the vetting of safety. once I know how
safe or unsafe it is,
now then I'm like, I'm ridiculously in
charge of how I show up in that space,
right?
I love this. I love the courage piece.
Something that I like to share with my
clients is when they're presenting
a scenario like you're presenting.
Well, what if this person, what if I go a
half step out of my comfort zone
and they insult me? You know,
they sneer at me. They make some snide
remark.
They talk about me behind
Yeah.
my back. And I'm like, well, any of those
things could happen.
Yeah.
I ask one question and
Yeah,
and
that's a great question.
What if it does? Because we're both
sitting there looking at each other,
knowing that these things are very real
possibilities.
Yeah, yeah.
We could go half a step out of our comfort
zone,
expose ourselves, expose our
vulnerabilities,
expose our weaknesses, and be chomped on,
right? Somebody could chomp right down for
their own reasons.
And then my question is always,
okay, what if that happens and...
and yeah.
And then they say, well, that's,
I wouldn't like that very much.
said, I understand that. And then they're
like,
well, they're going to talk about being
behind my back.
They probably will.
Yeah. Danny, you just like,
I think what you just said is such a,
such a wonderful way to bring back that
question about the scales,
the, the pain of not changing versus the
pain of changing.
Right. I mean, I think how you describe
that,
that stirs that right back up in my mind
of,
know, like, yep, those are possible.
And like, are we at a point where like,
I can't, I can't keep walking out of
meetings,
not giving my opinion. Right. Yeah.
Yeah, it's like what
are your choices? Your choices are just to
curl in on yourself
and never say anything or
Yeah.
take that risk and face those things and
lean into it and become stronger for it.
Yeah. Yeah, that's great.
know, that's
just, I think what we're discussing is ~
so pervasive.
~
Yeah.
Now I've got a few questions here that I
have a lot.
I don't think we're going to get to all of
them,
but I definitely want to get to your ERT
approach and make
plenty of space for that. So go ahead and
tell us all about your ERT approach.
Well, thanks. ~ And cut me off if I ramble
because I like this stuff a lot.
I will.
Okay,
great. Great. ~ So we would say,
you know, we believe transformation is
possible and we believe transformation
is just a long, slow, difficult process in
our lives.
That I've been doing stuff for decades,
it's going to take a long time to undo the
stuff that I'm doing if
I want to transform. But we think if...
If we can give the closest thing to a
silver bullet or a magic wand that we
can't,
we would say it is the practice of
reflection,
especially around encounters. So those are
the two pieces of our equation there.
E is encounter, R is reflection.
And here's how we define encounter.
We think every day, every one of us has
dozens of encounters,
meaning we have experiences or
interactions where we are thrown off.
thrown off our game. Either we're shocked
or surprised and then we react
or we lash out or we withdraw in.
Somebody cuts us off in traffic.
Somebody puts our shopping cart ahead of
ours in line.
Like we get an email that's unexpected and
difficult.
Those are encounters where we have the
potential to react instead of respond.
So then we would say when we have those,
dozens a day potentially, when we have
those,
the invitation is to reflect on it ~ and
ask some simple questions.
What happened? Who was there? What
emotions did I feel?
What did I do? And most importantly,
if I could do it again, would I do the
same thing?
And we believe that that practice of being
able to answer those questions,
especially those last ones, allow most of
us adults to see what is so.
And once we see it, we can't unsee it.
We can choose not to do something about
it,
but we don't get to unsee it.
We think most adults, our sort of
optimistic view is most adult leaders want
to change it if they don't prefer it.
And that then is the T, the
transformation,
that we have an encounter, we get to see
how we showed up in it.
Once we see it, now we get to choose what
to do with it,
which leads to transformation.
That is fabulous. love that. I love the
whole reflection thing.
There's so much power in that.
So as you're talking, I'm thinking of all
the different conversations I've
had with so many people over the years.
And I'm wondering what your thoughts are
on how this applies to a narcissist.
Mmm.
Because I've also I've had encounters,
you know, with narcissists. And also I've
talked to people who were struggling
in relationships with a narcissist
Yeah.
and
their ability, a narcissist's ability to
reflect seems interesting.
And so I was
Yeah, yeah.
wondering what your thoughts are.
If someone is listening that maybe they're
like,
somebody has accused me of having
narcissistic tendencies.
Maybe I need to lean into this.
Or if somebody's listening and they're
like,
my husband or my wife or my best friend or
whoever is a flaming narcissist,
Yeah. Yeah.
what should I expect?
you know, in terms of that reflection in
Yeah.
someone who has narcissism.
Yeah, that's a great question,
Dana. And I'll answer only if you promise
you'll answer too.
~
Okay?
So I am probably not wholly ~ qualified to
talk about narcissism,
but I think if we imagine the audience of
our E plus R equals C,
it's probably not a narcissist.
~ We imagine that ~ narcissists in general
have a hard time ~
thinking beyond what sort of a
self-serving posture.
I also think, Dana, that most leaders have
a certain level of narcissism.
I think it's a spectrum rather than a
yes-no.
It is. It is absolute spectrum.
Yeah, so I always want to be a little
careful,
but I think the most hardcore narcissists
are probably not ever going
to find reflection a practice worth
engaging in,
let alone a practice that... ~
that provides insight. And that's my
cynicism coming out there.
I don't like, how would you answer?
I certainly, I mean, we probably have an
optimistic view to say most people aren't
at that level of narcissism, that it's not
helpful.
But I think there probably is a level of
narcissism that reflection is just
not a tool that's gonna do much.
Yeah, I love the whole spectrum because
that's 100 % true.
Like virtually everything in life,
there's a spectrum.
Yeah.
we all, know, people who have accomplished
a lot in their life,
they, know, graduate degrees in politics,
you know, these types of things,
Yeah.
there's some
narcissism involved there. So it
absolutely is a spectrum.
It doesn't mean it's dysfunctional,
Yeah. Yeah.
but it can
reach a point where it is dysfunctional.
And really, as you're talking,
I was thinking,
of the people that I've talked to who have
been trying to navigate
a relationship with someone who is a
narcissist and they don't have that
reflection
Yeah. Yeah.
ability,
that's where I would come in with
boundaries.
Because I would come in and say,
Mmm. I love that. Yeah.
know, okay, well,
you're in an encounter with someone who is
dysfunctionally narcissistic.
and they're not respecting you,
they might be behaving in a way that is
somewhat abusive,
~ verbally, emotionally, whatever,
then with a boundary, then we have a right
and responsibility
Yeah. Yeah.
to keep ourselves safe. And so there's
all different kinds of ways of setting
that boundary with someone.
When we recognize, despite everything that
we say,
Yeah.
they're not going to engage in that
reflection.
They're
Yeah.
not going to see it.
And so it's kind of like, okay,
then we can set that boundary and let them
not see it.
Okay, I like to use a yard
Yeah, yeah.
analogy. They're in their yard,
we're in our yard. They're not gonna see
it.
Okay, that's in their yard. And just
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
set a boundary and move forward and stop
expecting blood to come out of a stone.
It's not going to happen.
Yeah, yeah.
I think you're spot on. we, we,
listen, I mean, I think there's a lot of
coaches that will help people
try to think about like, how do I change
someone I'm in a relationship with
or how do we just don't think that's
possible.
So, so we think for sure. I mean,
I love what you said. Like this is an
encounter with someone who's
a narcissist that that is going to be
true.
So, so then I think our question would be
how do we want to show
up knowing that that's true?
Like let's pretend that's just gonna be
true.
So then I still have control of how I show
up in that space,
whatever that needs to look like or
whatever boundary that needs to be.
I think that's a great, that's a great
point,
Dana.
Yeah. So let's see here. Now here's a good
question.
How do you help leaders get unstuck?
That's a question.
Because how many times do we, I'm just
stuck.
I'm stuck in this space. I can't get
unstuck.
What is it that you share with them?
If there's someone listening or someone
watching and they're in a leadership role,
but they're just, my first question is to
you,
what kind of, what have they shared with
you?
Where are they stuck? What are they stuck
in?
Is it some internal they're stuck or
they're stuck in terms
of how they're interacting with the people
they're supposed to be leading?
where are they stuck and how is it that
you help them become unstuck?
Yes, stuck is such a weird word,
isn't it?
Ahahaha!
Yeah. So we see a couple of common themes.
I think one theme we see is this sort of
inner critic or imposter syndrome where
there's just a stuckness of like,
yeah, I don't know how to take a step away
from this or take a step out of this.
That's one common area. The other common
area is I'm not getting the results that
I want, whether in my career or with the
people that I lead.
And I just don't know what else to try.
~ Those are pretty common. Most is like,
I'm not getting the career results I want,
or I'm not getting the opportunities that
I want.
~ Our approach to this, Dana,
is that the solution to the stuckness or
the getting unstuck is already
in our clients. Our posture is that it's
our job to ask the right question
at the right time to uncover the solution.
~
Every coach is a little different,
but we don't necessarily believe that it's
our job to prescribe a bunch
of ~ directions. We want to prescribe some
practices and some rhythms
to help get to those solutions.
But we think that if we can ask the right
question as an outsider looking in,
as someone not emotionally tied to a
situation,
if we can ask the right question,
we think that will help uncover the
solution that's already inside of our
clients.
Yeah, that sounds like a lot of what I
heard in grad school.
~ Socratic questioning and also I think it
was Carl Rogers that was really
all about providing unconditional positive
regard.
That if you gave your client unconditional
positive regard,
then the truth that was already in them
will have safe space to kind
of come forth and emerge. ~
Yeah, yeah.
And you can get at that through the
questions.
So that's wonderful.
For the people that want to access you,
that want to know more about you,
Kurt, that want to really find out more
what's going on,
the website that I have is
brimstonecoachinggroup.com.
Is that where you want them to go?
Heck yeah, that's right. That's right.
Yep, on the website, there's lots of ~
ways to find out who we are,
why we do what we do. I do have a partner,
I have a coaching partner. He's one of my
best friends.
We get to do this together and there's all
sorts of ways to connect with
us free of charge to see if our sort of
approach might be good to help
a listener get unstuck. If I may,
we have something we're really excited
about.
It's called Attending. It's a 10-day
online course.
It's completely free.
~ It's an invitation to take 10 days and
to be present to what's stirring
on the inside of us. ~ No calls to action,
no fixing, just ~ a 10 day experience
where we might begin to attend
to what's going on inside of us.
That's free on the website in our courses
section.
We just want people to have it and have
some space to create some intentional
space
to understand what's going on inside of
them right now.
That's fabulous. Thank you for that.
That's wonderful. Kurt, this has been
really enjoyable.
I am so thankful for you and you being
willing to come on Phoenix in Flame
and give us your expertise and your wisdom
and your vulnerability
and your stories with myself, with my
listeners,
with the viewers. Thank you, Kurt,
very, very much.
Yeah, thanks, Dana. It's been great.
Thanks for having me.
Listeners, viewers, I know that you have
heard multiple things today from Kurt that
you're thinking, this is fabulous.
I have a best friend. I have a coworker.
I have a family member that needs to hear
this.
Take this podcast episode,
copy and paste the link. You can share it
through text.
You can share it through email.
Post it on your favorite social media
sites.
so that we can grow our Phoenix and Flame
community and let people know
you are not alone. I hope your day has
been great.
I hope the rest of your day is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.